[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i have the honor of being joined
by henry lawful and gil kennen
who direct and wrote a boy called
christmas and i have this star here
nicholas himself with me it is out now
on netflix there's going to be spoilers
in this interview so make sure you watch
the film first before you watch this
interview how you guys doing today we're
doing great really nice to meet you
nice to meet you
um henry what were you feeling when you
first were told you got the lead part of
nicholas
um well as you could expect like i was
ecstatic because you know i've never
been
involved or ever had such a massive
opportunity and for it to be
my first role in such a massive
production doing
such an amazing story with such amazing
cast yeah it was it was incredible
yeah and you totally stepped to the
plate for it and a really good job by
you and
gil i absolutely love this film and
everything you do with it writing and
directing wise but what is the process
for you adapting a popular book into a
screenplay like this and how do you kind
of decide what to keep in and what to
cut
the process is not screwing it up
um the the the work of adapting a book
especially one as beloved as a boy
called christmas you know matt hague
through his writing is able to touch so
many people around the world and what
got me hooked on this story was how he
wrote nicholas as a sort of role doll
character a kid who has the weight of
the world on his shoulders keeps having
misfortune after misfortune and is still
persistent to go after one dream one
goal and of course that goal is going to
change his life and ours so what i
wanted to do is to make sure that i
could capture as much of that hero's
journey as inspired me when i read
matt's book and then to put on the page
the same sense of joy and wonder and
magic that i used to feel
at christmas time
and that i also used to feel in movie
theaters when i saw big fantasy films
that felt like they opened up the
ceiling of what a story could show and
so
kind of the synthesis of all of those
ideas came together to become the
screenplay for a boy called christmas
yeah and it shows in the screenplay but
it translates to the screen too which is
so impressive they will do both um no
problem
henry my question for you here is your
scene partner in this film a lot is a
mouse uh what are you actually talking
to and looking at and was that
challenging
um
most of the time i'm talking to a little
metal pin on my shoulder which was just
a magnet underneath my jacket and
most of the time i was talking to gil to
be honest um wow
yeah i i i do a mean mouse you know i'll
never
i'll i'll never um i'll never let steven
merchant off the hook for coming in and
stealing my best lines in this film yeah
i think
i think you missed an opportunity
casting yourself to be honest
thanks so much henry there's always a
sequel say that yeah
never know
um yeah no that that's actually really
funny to hear and
uh that's interesting too sometimes when
the director's the one you're kind of
speaking to while doing it that's really
cool um yeah now
gil is there any other christmas films
that kind of inspired you of how you
were gonna bring this to the screen
yeah i mean my favorite christmas films
um
sort of
there's a couple of them i'll mention
one is a christmas story because it's a
stone cold tonal classic like the way
that that film
messes with your expectations of family
and holiday and all of the trappings
that you take for granted and sort of
bends them inside out
it has made it timeless and
a perennial we watch it almost every
year
the other one i'll mention is is sort of
more recent in my in my life but made a
huge impact on me which is nightmare
before christmas and
when when that film came out i was in
high school i remember we all went as a
as a drama class to go see it and
it felt like a vision of a new way to to
see a holiday that everyone sort of took
for granted and uh and and so i think
that it was a reminder that just because
something is
classic and tried and true
doesn't mean that you can't find a new
way to see it and a new point of view
and so that was that was really
inspiring
yeah that's a great answer and and
nightmare for christmas is my favorite
christmas film so that that's cool and i
i can see that you can take it as
inspiration for just trying to be
different unique which which is really
cool i love that um
henry for you was it surreal working
with actresses like kristen wiig and
sally hawkins and did you kind of get to
learn anything from them
yeah obviously like
growing up i've been a massive harry
potter fan like i hate reading to be
honest don't tell me i said that but um
like i i read all the harry potter books
i remember i used to just sit at school
in primary school reading the book so
and then watching the films obviously i
love the films and to be working with um
maggie smith's gym broadbent um toby
jones three massive harry potter stars
it's obviously yeah like you said it's
surreal it's amazing i remember the
first time i met jim broadbent who i've
watched for years as professor slughorn
in harry potter was sitting on a [ __ ]
bronco in the middle of a studio um
pretending to be riding the reindeer
through the sky which is pretty crazy
um so yeah it's amazing and then
obviously
all the other actors kristen wiig um
stephen merchant who i only met two days
ago but to hear to
to um listen to his voice in the in the
adr which i did with gil yeah that was
fun but yeah it's amazing like such a
massive cast hopefully one day could be
up there with them names but yeah
oh hell yeah you're gonna get there i
see it um it's exciting that you're just
being with them that's so cool and
um i want to run off what you said to uh
gil where you were talking about
you know having that feeling of standing
out was there anything
in your mind going into this looking at
other christmas films and this being its
own christmas what did you want to do
with this film to make it stand out from
the rest of people and just be like i've
seen this before you know
well
first of all i had a lot of confidence
in the story that uh that came from the
book what matt haig wrote new i knew
that this was going to be an original
take on this on this holiday because the
story is
such a
clean sheet approach to the legend of
santa claus so i had a lot of confidence
that we were going to be able to go in a
very new direction but one of the things
that
that as a film i was excited to do
was to sort of break a barrier that
really hasn't happened much in this sort
of film which is to take the camera
properly to the arctic circle we went up
to the very edge of lapland in finland
uh to begin the film making process on
this film in the dead of winter and some
of those wide open vistas where you can
almost see the curvature of the earth
gives the film this sort of scope that
we just don't expect from a film that
comes out in the holiday season so for
me that was like a really exciting way
to leap into this story
yeah and i i totally felt that watching
a big scope of it which was just an awe
to watch and also how good the cgi
looked it was it was pretty pretty cool
um no problem uh so
henry did you find anything though in
the character of nicholas that you felt
like you could relate to as a person
yeah um i think nicholas
for most people is a really relatable
character and i think that's
through the journey he he goes through
obviously it's a very exaggerated
journey but it it
almost shows people's day-to-day lives
like the way the the huge ups and downs
that that the character goes through
obviously don't want to ruin it but
losing his parents and then coming to
to to become father christmas i guess
and and and flying on a reindeer with a
king and doing all these amazing things
after going through these ups and downs
it's like a roller coaster and i feel i
guess that's how at times
i do and i'm sure many people feel like
and so it's not just one
straight easy ride for him i feel like
it's relatable for people's lives and
that's one of the things i guess um
that
is good to show through the character um
for people watching to give a message
that
you know there's always
light at the end of the tunnel and like
you know there's always there's always
good to come even at your lowest points
to always believe in yourself and hope
and yeah i think his optimism
um
yeah i'll try my best to be optimistic
it's hard i i doubt it
um
americans might not be as aware of the
football but yeah being a tottenham fan
myself over here yeah it's hard to be
optimistic but um yeah i'll try my best
no yeah and you bring that optimism joy
to the role really well which which
really helps the film like stand down
and shine and
uh you know
gill i have to ask two you know
is there a favorite sequence of yours to
film in this movie because there was so
many fun ones to watch i couldn't kind
of pick my favorite but is there
anything that you had the most fun kind
of filming
well
one of the most fun was also one of the
hardest there was a scene that we shot
very early in the film henry will
remember this because we dragged the
cast and crew up on snowmobiles to the
top of a mountain in slovakia
and we filmed on a frozen lake and we
had to keep checking by poking poles to
make sure that it was frozen enough to
get the equipment onto and it was the
scene right before nicholas finds elf
helm so he is discovered in the snow by
father toppo and little noosh and they
revive him using some elf magic
in that scene
as we started to film it a a a real snow
storm began and so the wind was blowing
and snow started coming down while we
were filming
and it was one of the first days of
proper filming on this on this show and
it just felt like magic like you know i
couldn't believe my luck
at being able to capture all of that on
camera i also
felt a deep sense of cold that came up
from my toes all the way through my legs
that basically didn't stop until we were
almost at the end of the shoot
but
it was uh it was an extraordinary moment
because it was a commitment to telling
this story in the real world as much as
possible and uh and so i'll never forget
it
yeah and that's such a cool story here
because i think people love hearing when
they're seeing such a wild film an
awesome film just wild stories that
happen while making it like that there
is that
meta connection in a way it was an
adventure making this film was an
adventure
there you go uh
now henry do you
right now feel excited or how are you
feeling just about the spotlight this
film will put you in that it's gonna
really put you on the map like are you
nervous like what what is kind of going
through your head right now um to be
honest for me right now i'm i'm not
really sure what to expect like i've
never been in a situation anything like
this i've been in the bbc adaptation of
les mis for about two and a half seconds
so um so then going onto onto a project
like this and you know it's been over
two years since we've done it um for it
to now be shown to the world obviously
i'm really excited to see how it does
and people's reactions to it because i
think
gill um complimenting you again done a
really good job um
made me look like a good actor i think
apparently um so
um
yeah i'm yeah obviously excited um
no i'm not really sure what to expect
but hopefully it's the start of bigger
things to come for me uh in my career
and
yeah
just see where things go i guess yeah
i'll just say that what what we've seen
in this conversation is the
clear-headedness and ground groundness
uh groundedness of henry i mean it's the
same
the same character traits that made me
so excited to cast him as nicholas and
tell this story with him because you can
you can tell
just in this conversation that there is
an accessibility to who henry really is
not just a sort of veneer that can
happen a lot of times with younger
actors and um and so i just have so much
confidence in henry's ability to grow
into whatever character he's cast in in
future films because what he puts into
it is his own intelligence experience
and his ability to tap into his emotions
yeah that's that's an amazing compliment
right there and yeah he's just been a
class act this whole time which is
awesome to see henry and
before i let you guys go i have to ask a
million dollar question could we see the
next two books in this book series
possibly made into a film
um so i'll answer that i've had such a
great time making this film working with
blueprint and
studio canal and netflix to bring a boy
called christmas to the screen the cool
thing is that through this process i've
become really close friends with matt
haig who just happens to write the
remaining books in this series and i'm
happy to say that we're starting to
figure out how to how to crack those
next books into future installments
and so if audiences this christmas
uh feel as much passion about nicholas
and his world as we all feel then i
would say you know
it doesn't hurt to hope yeah hell yeah
that's so exciting to hear
everybody
check out a boy called christmas it's on
netflix now uh watch gil and henry just
make magic happen on screen
henry gill thank you so much for joining
me guys i hope to talk to you in the
future one day thanks that was fun
thanks thank you